what do people not understand about
anxiety it's something that I feel is
very complex especially for women
because I know like if my progesterone's
low
I literally I told my husband it was
like two days ago I was in right after
ovulation
estrogens dropping and I'm like I looked
at him and I'm like if you could be in
my head right now
it's like hell I was like it's like hell
like when you're progesterone you know
I'm gonna make enough progesterone like
my I get body anxiety to wear everything
in me vibrates it's like someone plugged
me into a wall socket and it is no
matter what I do I can breathe I can
meditate I can do all the things but
nothing works and I think
you know there's all these tools that we
have and at some point sometimes nothing
works and I think the people around us
have to be compassionate to that
um because there's just some days that
you know there's so many like I said so
many components there's a hormonal
component there's
um you know if I'm really triggered by
something you know that that from trauma
um which seems to be for me now I think
my anxiety is definitely
um there's a there's a more
there's a physical component to it as
far as like like I said hormonally I
think
um is a huge piece for me that that
definitely um exacerbates the problem
so yeah I think I think people don't
realize
how layered and complex
anxiety can be and how many different
triggers we can have you know what can
be triggering it because there's there's
so many layers to it what's the best way
to love someone through that yeah
oh
let it I I appreciate it when my husband
allows me to verbalize it and let it be
um and not try to fix it but just just
sees me like you know that I can say in
my mind is a freaking living hell right
now and he's okay with it and it it
doesn't
we can still go about life but I'm just
and I think that's really it's good for
me to be able to verbalize it too
um so you know I don't feel like I'm
trapped in my own hell because I think
for a lot of people I I I'm sure a lot
of people relate to that for me it feels
like I'm trapped inside of a cell and
um
if I don't express to people what's
going on around me it Feels So Lonely
yeah so I think you know just allowing
for that person to express what's going
on inside is for me it's really helpful
and cathartic because it as soon as I
vocalize it
it's like the elephant just got you know
it's now out of the room and yeah
um there's some space around it well
anxiety correct me if I'm wrong is kind
of uh isolating in and of itself like
it's a it's a mental Loop so if you're
already kind of in your head and then if
you can't verbalize it's like really
isolating yeah absolutely for me
sometimes the the body anxiety can be so
intense and it's and then all of a
sudden I will get in my head about just
the fact that I can't control what's
going on
um so
you know accepting acceptance is huge
knowing that I do have tools
um and knowing that it will pass like
that's sort of been one of the biggest
things for me
I know everybody's like everything's
temporary and my mind goes to yeah but
how long is it gonna take
how long is this Gonna Last and now it's
like okay I can ride this wave and you
know I think that acceptance is huge
because I I have started to notice that
it really it really is a wave and it
will it will come and it will go
um I Heard I've heard you talk about
dancing before is that and like exercise
I've heard is a really good thing like
getting the body to move and kind of
blowing off some of the energy through
movement but I think somatic uh healing
is is really also along with EMDR I feel
like are really some very powerful
modalities that I think will become more
and more common so
um do
I was just at this I was just at this
festival and we did
um they called it fluent body and they
kind of wanted you to think it was maybe
yoga but you really just got there and
you just sort of flailed your body
around for an hour and let me tell you I
get why dancers are fit AF because
um it was a lot of work
um but you know just being able to move
your body and like use like voice and
sound uh do you do that stuff yeah
absolutely sound is so powerful
um and you know it's totally a thing in
your voice like hello yeah but that's
what I was gonna say it's so interesting
because I
I've always used my voice for other
people and it was the last place I went
for myself
and so I that's why I started chanting
you know and and now one of the
practices that I do is I'll just go make
sounds I don't need it to sound pretty
because you know all my sound usually
comes out sounding pretty and I usually
I'm controlling it in some way and I
think I love that you talk about
flailing your body around it's so nice
to just let our bodies and our voices
move and have movement and create sounds
because
I think there's so much freedom and just
the expression of the energy that wants
to come through us and not
focusing on how it has to look and for
someone who's been so much in the public
eye my whole life and I've been so
concerned about how I look and how I
sound
it's such a freeing experience and it's
really uncomfortable I can honestly I'll
go up and do it maybe for like three or
five minutes but past that I'm like I'm
really uncomfortable it it I can't get
out of my head about it but I'll allow
myself those few minutes to do it I've
gotten to where I can do it a little bit
longer here and there but
um
it does it bring up yes oh my God I can
be dancing to a really joyful song and
just bawl my eyes out because it's the I
that the freedom that expression without
control it goes back to the child like
the child who thought that I had to
control everything
um there's so much grief there actually
and so to touch upon that grief it's
like I can like dip a toe and then like
come out of it
um but I've I've I've held myself there
in moments where I've just let it
overtake me and it's um it's a powerful
practice it really is have you ever
heard of Taran Toomey
um it's a great it's a it's a work out
it's not crazy workout but it's a little
bit of a workout but it's like 45
minutes to an hour and you just like
play one song there's one song that
plays and you just do the same movement
through it and eventually sometimes you
add like
like your breath and stuff to it
um and then they do a hard opening at
the end and I would say about 80 of the
time that I've done one of the classes
um I've like for sure shed a tear or
cried or had some
but it's this cool blend of being able
to just move your body for a for
physical you know activity and strength
and flexibility but then also pairing
that up with the voice and stuff and
music and the verbal prompting that they
do with you like what's happening what's
in there what are you coming up against
like what's the story you're telling
yourself all that kind of stuff just
starts to like really ruffle it up I
don't know which I like it it just came
to mind because I feel like I've had so
much cool stuff come through that I'm
gonna have to try that what was the
other thing you were you said you did at
the festival yeah uh oh it was called
fluent body but it was it was I'm not
really sure if that's like a class that
you can do I think it's just this sweet
I think she was maybe Italian I'm not
sure but she was about it okay leading
leading us with music and you know kind
of allowing us to flail around sometimes
really vigorously sometimes really soft
right sometimes with their eyes open we
gazed at each other it was six girls and
at one point in time were literally dead
panning staring at each other and you
know that kind of stuff that kind of
stuff that's fun you love dancing though
right I feel like I've heard about it
yeah so that's no that's been a real rub
for me like a place where I've been
really uncomfortable I used to dance as
a child and then I don't remember who it
was it doesn't really matter but someone
told me that I was a better singer that
I was a dancer when I was young and it
kind of stunted that piece of me
and also growing up in front of the
public eye and like I said you know
people wanting to keep you a kid and
then they're growing into your own body
as a woman and
and then being sexualized and it was
just I kind of was like I don't feel
comfortable in my skin and dancing with
all of that
um
just felt yeah it felt like very
uncomfortable and so that's been one of
the areas like I said where I've really
uh I really learned to to be gentle with
myself and like I said if I get in there
for one song it's like okay I that's an
edge for me so I want to hear about I
want to hear about them you know some
point down the line when you're like I
dance naked for an hour and there's a
mirror and I would like you know it's
funny because I I love I love the full
moon and I I literally have a deep
desire to like go out naked under the
full moon and dance so I think I think I
need to I think you saying that is my
cue to like do that next time speaking
things into existence I mean there's
something obviously happening in the
quantity I'm curious your thoughts about
it like the fact I don't know if it
happens to you but sometimes it does
like something like that that you have
that thought about doing that but I have
no idea why I said that I don't really
know why those words came out of my
mouth but this field around us is
holding all the information
and I sometimes think that that's the
information from the field just sort of
coming into my awareness and some level
that feels like mine but it's not mine
it's in the field and it's partly it's
it's something to do with our
conversation
um but it's uh it's it's it's it's it's
fascinating to think about how much we
don't know is going on
oh yeah it's insane and I think it's
beautiful like we're all Messengers for
one another I mean I think that's why
relationship is so important because
and I I like this is why I love these
conversations I end up walking away with
something like that
and I think if you're open
you know
as a Creator we're all creators
um but I also you know I'm such a it's
creativity is such a huge part of my job
and writing and
creating and so I'm constantly open to
life like I'm constantly looking and
listening and
um for inspiration and so I'm really
I feel like I'm really tapped into that
you know once we once we open ourselves
up to
to all of the signs and things that come
into our awareness
I feel like it's it's there all the time
you know and I mean it is there all the
time it's just once we open ourselves up
we we now have we're focused you know
our focus is is we're receptive to it so
if you like this clip and you want to
hear the whole episode click at the
bottom of your screen
[Music]